- Well, coming up, we
actually have some nurses
and doctors who helped
you at the hospital.
- Oh yeah.
- Yes. So what's
something that you learned
from your experience there?
- Well, you know, nurses, I mean,
we all know doctors make
pretty good money, but nurses
you know, so I thought
maybe we could do something.
I think they'll be surprised
when they come outside.
- I know. I'm very excited.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And you don't realize,
like, how, I mean,
even when I had kids,
like when I was pregnant
I had like horrible pregnancies
and was hospitalized
for both of them.
And I mean, they are like angels.
Like when you really can't move.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- You can't do anything.
- Yeah.
- They're just like the best humans ever.
- Yeah. It really is.
- This was pre Covid.
I knew this.
- And very nice and very, yeah.
I really enjoyed their company
and they do, especially
when you're dealing
with burn victims, you know?
Because that's really
a tough one, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I saw how they
interacted with other patients
and with little kids and stuff.
- Yeah.
- So I thought we should,
at least people get a chance to meet them.
- Yeah. Lift them up.
All right.
(clapping)
As I might have mentioned,
Jay's had his fair
share of mishaps lately.
First fire erupted while he
was working on one of his cars.
Then he broke his collarbone
in a motorcycle accident.
Have I missed anything?
- Well, what I was, I
was riding my motorcycle.
I came around the corner
and I crashed into
Jeremy Renner's snowplow.
That was a --
- You cra--
(laughs)
- But how easy is she to fool?
- Oh my God.
I was like, you what?
I'm gullible.
You know this.
Okay, fortunately, Jay is as good as new
thanks in part to truly
awesome medical care, y'all.
We have one of his doctors
and his team of nurses
from Grossman Burn Centers
at West Hills Hospital joining us now.
Before I introduce them,
I do wanna let you know we'll
be showing a couple pictures
of Jay's burns that may be
considered graphic to some.
So keep that in mind.
All right, then, let's say
hi to Dr. Peter Grossman.
Karen, Alyssa, and Amy.
(clapping)
- Here's how.
There you go.
The Grossman Burn Center is probably
the best burn center in the country.
We're lucky to have it
here in Los Angeles.
Show you how good he is.
He is 104 years old, looking at him.
He looks fantastic.
(laughs)
Born in the late eighteen hundreds.
Yeah. Yeah. You right?
It's amazing.
- Walking marketing. It's amazing.
- It really is an amazing
place when you realize
I mean, it's eight days,
you know, it's like
you know those glasses in about an hour.
New face in about eight days
- Honestly, we said this
at the commercial break.
I thought you were joking
earlier when you said new ear.
I thought you were being sarcastic.
It's a new ear.
- What?
(laughs)
Uh?
- You can't tell.
I literally got right up in there.
I was like, what?
I was like, y'all are incredible.
I'm gonna get to that.
(audience cheering)
But I gotta ask,
when Jay Leno, a national
treasure, walks into your place
what do you do when he comes in?
What did you think?
- I mean, you have to stay professional.
You know, it's our job.
So, you know, he was great though.
He came in like anybody else.
And, you know, we really wanted to get him
into the hyperbaric chamber immediately.
Cause he had facial burns
and we wanted to get
those, the swelling down.
- Yeah.
- So he did that.
But then he, you know,
I was his admitting nurse.
I was about to admit him.
And then he was like,
"All right I gotta get home to my wife".
And we're like, no, no,
no, you have to stay.
- What?
- And get admitted.
And he promised us he was gonna go home
and come back the next morning.
And we were concerned, you know,
'cause his burns were
extensive, but he kept his word.
He was back first thing in the morning.
So, yeah.
- You left?
(audience laughs)
- Well cause my wife didn't know anything
about what was going and
wanted to reassure her.
So, I went home for us.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Then I came back the next morning, so.
- This is why you've
been married this long.
- That's how you stay married 43 years.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Exactly.
- I wouldn't know Jay.
(laughs)
So Alyssa, what, what do you
remember from this moment?
- So I came into work and
you know a whole bunch
of people were like, oh yeah, you know,
somebody like really important
is here, da da da da.
I went with Amy.
She was like, come on,
let's go see our patient.
I walked in, Jay's there
with all of his friends
there's In-N-Out on the table.
And then Karen, Amy and I were just like,
okay, let's get down to business
and do his dressing and, you
know, get him taken care of.
- Yeah. Karen, what happened with you?
- So I take the triage calls for all
of our burn patients as a charge nurse.
And I got a call from
a doctor and he said,
"Listen, I have a patient
that's a big celebrity
that has burns on his face".
And I'm thinking, okay, what
movie was he an extra in?
You know, in LA everyone's a celebrity.
- They were hoping for Brad Pitt. (laughs)
- [Kelly] No but everyone's--
- No, it's Leno. Don't.
(laughs)
- And then he said Jay
Leno and I was like,
"Okay, wow, yes this is big".
And I initially thought of his cars
'cause we all know Jay loves his cars
and that was how the burn happened.
So we saw him shortly thereafter.
And initially when I saw him
I for sure knew he had
second degree burns,
but they looked to be deep second
even maybe third degree burns.
And when you have deep burns on your face
your face swells a lot.
And so there's a risk
with all that swelling
that your airway could be compromised.
So it was very serious
and we were trying to relay that to him.
And he's like,
"I'll be back in the
morning. I'll be back".
And so.
- Oh my.
(laughs)
- Off he went and you kind
of felt like you were letting
your kid go and you're like,
"Bye, please come back in the morning".
And the next morning he showed up
and we were just so relieved to see him
that he was talked to his
wife, decided to come back.
And then we just, from there,
we got on with his care.
- Oh my gosh.
Okay. So how would you
rate Jay as a patient?
Amy, I'll start with you.
How is he?
- Oh, I mean, he was amazing.
He was as funny as you'd
think he'd be and, you know
kept his humor and,
you know, he really didn't wanna be there.
Not that anyone wants to be there,
but he was working a lot
and really was trying to get
home as quickly as possible.
So I think in that sense
he really did everything
he was supposed to do.
We, you know, he went
into the oxygen chamber
as much as we needed him to.
And it's really a testament
to how quickly he recovered.
He did great.
- Yeah.
- He was also just quite
lovely with all of us.
- I mean, my gosh, y'all are incredible.
That is, it looks like nothing happened.
I can't keep saying it enough.
- I'm sorry to disappoint you, yeah.
- No, no.
(audience laughs)
I'm just, it looks like--
- No, we thought he'd be burned up.
- No, you know, I don't want that.
But I just, it's crazy how
talented people can be at that.
(audience cheering)
So, Doctor Grossman,
your dad actually started
the burn center, right?
after an orphanage fire in Chicago.
Is this right?
- There was a parochial school in Chicago
in 1958, called Our Lady of the Angels.
And back at that time,
there wasn't a whole lot
of burn care that was well defined.
And my father was working as
a resident in this hospital
called Cook County Hospital in Chicago.
And ninety nine children and nuns came in,
almost all of them were deceased
and that was his impetus
to go into burn care.
And he became a plastic surgeon
and then opened up the burn
center here in Los Angeles
back in the late sixties.
And fortunately nepotism
was very good to me.
(audience laughs lightly)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He gave me a job when I came out.
- And so I was able to kind
of join my dad in practice.
- What a beautiful story
'cause something so horrible.
But to make something
beautiful out of that
and help others
because that could change people.
You know what I'm saying?
If you didn't have that technology,
it would change people's confidence,
like their personality, all
of that would be affected.
So Dr. Grossman, is Jay
fully recovered from burns?
- Well, you know, everything changes.
So he's done remarkable.
I mean, when I first saw Jay,
I was a little uneasy
because when I saw him,
he was a little bit more
significantly burned
than I had hoped.
And so you knowing that
it's Jay Leno and a face
that everybody recognizes,
there's a little bit
of angst going on there.
And as I, as I'm leaving
his room for the first time
he goes, "Hey, yeah, hey
Doc, listen to this".
- That was an impression
of me, by the way.
- That was your impression.
(laughs)
- And he, and so he
turns on his cell phone
and he goes,
"Hey Jay, it's Joe".
(laughs)
"I just wanna let you know,
I'm in Indonesia right now,
but I'm thinking about you.
I heard about your accent
and I'm praying for you".
And Jay goes, "Isn't that nice?"
And I go, yeah.
And I walk away,
I go, "That's the president
of the United States".
(laughs)
No pressure now.
- No pressure.
- I think he did that on
purpose to me as I walked out
just so I made sure I stayed in line.
- That's so funny that you said that.
'Cause my mother does this in
every doctor's appointment,
She will somehow slide it
in that I'm her daughter.
She'll like, yeah, as if
it puts pressure on them.
Like, don't screw this up.
Like she does that.
I don't know if it works, but she's fine.
- But he's a good healer.
He's, you know, there was a time I was,
we were in surgery one time
and I was having to shave
away some of the burn tissue
and I needed some counter
traction to do it.
And I'm recognized all of a sudden,
I'm pulling on this object to
gimme some counter traction
and oh, that's the chin,
that was Jay Leno's chin
that I'm using as my surgical
assistant right there.
And I will let you know.
It's all his right now.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's all his.
(laughs)
- That was the thing
that I think was the time
when I realized, all right,
this is more than usual
as far as pressure goes,
to make sure you don't mess things up.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you've ever seen --
- That is a national treasure, man.
- I know, I don't know if
you've ever seen his signature.
- [Kelly] Great job.
- But his signature is almost
a caricature of his chin
and I didn't wanna be the guy
who shortened his signature up,
so we had to make sure
that we were okay with it.
- Who'd screwed it all up.
(laughs)
- Well, we're gonna do a
benefit for the Grossman Center.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
(clapping)
- To help kids.
- Yeah.
- So Jay, what do you
wanna say to your team?
- I think we have a little
something for you guys as well.
- Okay. Okay.
- Just a way to say thank you.
- All right.
So, but first I believe your friends here
brought you something that
you don't know about yet, so.
- Oh.
- Yep.
(laughs)
And it came in a lovely pot.
- So cute.
So Jay, we love you.
- Yes.
- And we don't want you
to get hurt anymore.
- All right. I can see this coming.
Yes, yes.
- So, we'd like to give this to you.
- Okay, well thank you.
- I love that it came in there.
(laughs)
- I hope it's lasagna.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, it's a, please handle with--
- [Kelly] It says fragile?
(laughs)
- Here we go.
Alright, well there you go.
- [Kelly] Please handle with care.
- Thank you. Thank you.
(clapping)
- [Kelly] I love it.
- All right, now I, all right, all right.
To return the favor, I have
something for you guys.
- Okay, cool.
We are all grateful
to the nurses at Grossman Burn Centers
who helped Jay, a national
freaking treasure, heal.
(audience cheers)
We love him.
So, Karen, Alyssa and Amy.
That's why we are sending
you each plus a guest
on a four night trip to
Atlantis in The Bahamas.
- Oh my God.
(audience cheers louder)
Which is celebrating twenty
five years this year.
It's a beautiful place. Okay?
You'll experience
luxurious accommodations.
Fourteen unique pools.
Dine at world renowned restaurants.
Enjoy white sand beaches,
live entertainment.
Plus, you'll get to
see the world's largest
open air marine habitat.
It's so cool.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you guys so much.
What you do it's so wonderful.